Android Oh introduces a new icon format
called adaptive icons which aim to make
our home screens more coherent by
unifying the size and shape of all app
icons and open the door to interesting
visual effects with adaptive icons you
supply a 108 by 108 DP icon and the
device will apply a mask shape to it now
different devices or third-party
launchers choose what shape mask to use
for example they might use a simple
circle a rounded square or perhaps a
square call the mask is at most 72 by 72
DP but might be smaller in parts masks
are guaranteed not to touch the central
66 DP of your icon so this can be
considered a safe zone and you should
keep any parts of your icon that should
never be clipped within this area
adaptive icons comprise two separate
layers a background and a foreground
stacked on top of one another this
allows the device to offer interesting
visual effects by treating each layer
independently for example a launcher
might apply a parallax effect when the
icon is moving by translating the layers
at different rates that's why your
overall asset is larger than the mass
size the outer 18 DP on each side will
only ever be revealed when motion
effects are applied to add an adaptive
icon to your app create an adaptive icon
definition in XML like this where you
can specify which assets to use for the
foreground and background elements as
this will only ever be used on Android o
devices you can place this drawable in
the v26 configuration so that it
overrides your standard icon on newer
devices also new in Android o is the
ability to use vector drawables as
Launcher icons each of the foreground
and background elements can be a raster
asset like pings or web P a vector asset
or even a closed Roble the background
must be completely opaque while the
foreground can contain transparency if
your app also offers app shortcuts then
they should also update to use adaptive
icons shortcuts can be pinned to the
homescreen right next to app icons so
they need to fit in if you offer a
bitmap app shortcut such as users photo
then there's a new api on icon or icon
compact classes to create an adapter
icon from that to help you to create
these icons Android studio 3.0 offers an
updated wizard where you can import or
create the foreground and background
layers if you set your target SDK to
version 26 but don't supply an
interactive icon then some launchers
like the pixel launcher
we'll scale down your icon and place it
on a background so that's what you need
to know about making your icons adaptive
doing so will ensure they fit in with
other apps on the device and benefit
from the new possibilities for
displaying them
[Music]
you